entre ovaciones y protestas Japón
celebró el funeral de estado del ex
Primer Ministro xinzoave con ofrendas
florales tributos por parte de las
fuerzas militares y la asistencia de
unos 4.300 invitados sin suave fue
despedido en el pabellón nipón budokan
en Tokio el Primer Ministro japonés
fumío kicida elogio del trabajo de su
predecesor hizo significativamente más
fuerte la relación con Estados Unidos
fortaleció drásticamente el poder de
disuasión entre los dos países mejoró la
cooperación entre India y Australia su
diplomacia de múltiples niveles ha
creado buenas relaciones con todas las
regiones del mundo
una 190 delegaciones extranjeras
hicieron parte del homenaje Incluyendo a
la vicepresidenta estadounidense kamala
Harris el Primer Ministro indio narendra
modi y el australiano Anthony albanís de
latinoamérica representantes de Colombia
Honduras México Panamá y El Salvador
asistieron al tributo ave murió tras
recibir disparos el 8 de julio durante
un acto electoral cuatro días después se
celebró un funeral privado no obstante
fumioquicida decidió organizar un nuevo
funeral estimado en 11.5 millones de
dólares a cargo del Estado lo que ha
causado que cientos de japoneses salgan
a las calles a manifestarse en contra
del elevado costo del evento según una
reciente encuesta 60% de los ciudadanos
están en desacuerdo
no tengo absolutamente ninguna simpatía
por él realmente no tengo ningún
problema con las personas que sienten
tristeza por su muerte pero cuando el
luto se realiza en nombre de toda la
nación estoy también incluido en eso y
no lo puedo permitir hace 55 años de
Japón no celebraba un funeral de estado
desde el ex Primer Ministro shigeru
yoshida en 1967 quien lideró la
reconstrucción del país asiático tras la
Segunda Guerra Mundial
[Música]